yeah the HELOC thing I something I just
recently learned about too uh and we
could break it down what that is that's
obviously uh is that that's that's a
line of credit yeah you can take out
against your house right yeah a home
equity line of credit um and it's crazy
because people was using that to their
advantages was like like you said you
had equity in your home you could take
it out you can use it to for repairs you
can use it a lot of people are trying to
use it for other Investments or you
could just can't you take it out without
touching it and then it's there if you
need it right yeah exactly and then what
happened when we started getting
educated around it people started taking
advantage of it Banks started realizing
and they were like all right well we're
going to stop ordering this product
crazy right because it was like oh this
is an opportunity that people could use
to their advantage
um and so it's one of those things like
when you have the education and the
timing of of situations happen you got
to be prepared for it you got to be
ready to take action because again if
you don't they can pull the plug and say
all right well it was a great
opportunity but you're going to miss
this one do you guys feel like this like
kind of time that we're getting into
with a lot of the uh you know real
estate say kind of correcting obviously
the interest rates are higher but do you
feel like it's a it's it's soon I mean
it's it's kind of getting to be about
not not a
not a seller's market a buyer's market
you would think that that's coming soon
do you feel like there's going to be
some dope opportunities to
scoop real estate for a lot cheaper than
I mean obviously than a year and a half
ago you know [__] was crazy there's
always opportunities it's just hey it
depends geographically where you're at
right so
the LA Market is a lot different from
Milwaukee yeah where like right now you
could probably buy a home in Milwaukee
for thirty thousand dollars forty
thousand dollars you buy a building for
fifty thousand dollars right where you
can't even buy a closet for fifty
thousand dollars in LA right so there's
always opportunities it's just a matter
of a knowing where the opportunities are
um but be is it going to be a massive
correction
I don't think it'll be a massive
correction right um it'll probably be
some pullbacks in areas like Miami or
you know certain parts of New York like
where the real estate went up a lot yeah
I saw like Phoenix Austin like like a
lot of those hot markets where things
just got really crazy I feel like
they're gonna probably yeah I mean it's
the number one rule of investing no
matter whether it's Dogecoin whether
it's Tesla stock whether it's Miami real
estate what goes up must come down for
sure that's just like the most basic way
to think about anything in life and when
things start to not make sense
eventually it's going to start to cool
off very soon so like when you hear
Miami people paying over 500 000 over
asking and uh uh a quarter million
dollars over asking and buying things in
cash like it just got so so crazy the
last couple of years
yeah it has to pull back eventually
because it's not sustainable that's what
happened in Phoenix like uh everybody
sold their houses here because [__] was
at all-time high and they didn't care
going to a city like Phoenix that
they're moving to and they're the houses
are so much cheaper they're like oh I'll
pay 100 over that's still like I'm still
getting a mini mansion from where I was
just coming from and I still have
pocketed a few hundred thousand dollars
so yeah we'll see man